notre exploration de la cellule débute
sur la membrane externe on y trouve des
protéines qui flottent sur de petit
radeau ces protéines sont les antennes
de communication de la
cellule ici à l'intérieur de la cellule
vous avez une protéine qui fait face à
l'intérieur de la cellule mais l'autre
partie de la protéine est à l'extérieur
de la cellule comme ça vous avez une
communication entre l'extérieur de la
cellule et l'intérieur de la cellule
alors vous pouvez transmettre des
signaux de l'extérieur de la cellule à
l'intérieur en changeant la structure de
la protéine alors vous changez sa
conformation en trois dimensions et
c'est de cette façonlà que l'intérieur
de la cellule euh a une connaissance
d'exactement ce qui arrive à l'extérieur
de la cellule